by polluting the oceans not mitigating
co2 emissions and destroying our
biodiversity we are killing our planets
let's face it there is no planet B that
was French president Emmanuel macron
speaking before a joint session of
Congress on Tuesday and calling for
action on climate change in other
environmental threats this week one
growing concern was amplified by a new
scientific study German researchers
found much higher rates of plastic
particles in Arctic sea ice than were
previously known a form of contamination
that those small threatens life
throughout the region here to talk about
it is Time magazine editor at large
Jeffrey Kluger Jeffrey good morning good
morning let's talk in a little more
detail about what exactly micro plastics
are Jeff well the name says a lot micro
plastics generally come in under five
millimeters but the thing is the large
majority of them are much smaller on the
order of microns which is a thousandth
of a meter some of these things are 11
microns which is a sixth of the width of
a human hair
and in this case small is bad because
it's much easier to circulate through
the ecosystem and get into fish and to
work its way up through the food chain a
lot of beach bodies out there I mean
people are swimming in the ocean they
are eating assuming everything coming
out of the ocean what what does this
study really tell us well it tells us
first of all what we know that these
plastics can do they can disrupt genetic
expression which is huge they can cause
body-wide inflammation and we're
learning the numbers of the the
concentration of these things in a core
sample of ice about the size of a wine
bottle
they found 12,000 particles of micro
plastic in a clump of ocean soil just
two pounds
they found 6500 particles so these
things are ubiquitous do we know what
specific types of plastics they are they
are and there's some nasty ones there
are 17 different types of plastic
there's polyurethane there's
polyethylene there
plastic from from paints on boats
there's nylon there is cellulose from
cigarette filters and there's even
particles of car tires as they wear away
because remember these things are so
small that they become wind-borne and
then they float out into the ocean all
that stuff sounds really bad but they
still can't really tell us what it might
do to us if we do ingest or consume it
if we are swimming around with it and
well that's the problem and there are
two ways it gets into your system it
gets in on your skin it gets in if you
swallow water and again the biggest
concern is sea food fresh water fish
funnily enough absorb water through
their skin but marine fish the kind we
in supermarkets drink this water it is
impossible to keep this out of the food
chain with a fish heavy you and I are
going to and they breed the water and
they breathe the water exactly Jeffrey
how surprised were they to find this
well they weren't they were not
surprised to find that there are
plastics in there in in the sea ice and
in the water because other studies have
shown this but what they didn't expect
were the concentrations these
concentrations they found this time are
two and three times as high as the
concentration as before and a big part
of it is that Great Pacific Garbage
Patch we're hearing about which is twice
the size of Texas I mean it is our trash
it is our garbage what can we do to stop
the flow well there are a few things we
can do first of all in terms some of
what's causing this is over fishing
because fishing vessels come in
especially in this area around Siberia
and nylon Nets leech off particles
flaking paint has heavy plastic
components so you have to use different
kinds of nets you have to take better
care of your paint and you have to not
be overfishing these areas that are
fishing and that are overfishing any any
way when it comes to the Garbage Patch
it's going to take that a long time to
dissipate but what we have to be doing
is not dumping more of this garbage at
sea so these badges does it affect the
water effectively Jeffrey it does affect
the water effectively and the problem is
you get a swirl in so ocean
currents are what bring warmth to the
northern hemisphere which is fine but
everything in that water swirls
completely around us think about the
ocean as a great body with a great
pulsing heartbeat the currents are the
blood system the contaminants are
carried everywhere and so much of us yes
water oh my goodness Geoffrey Kugler
thank you so much thank you for having
me